all right so we'll get started sure so
hello everyone you see lots of friendly
faces many known thank you for joining
us tonight for stoicism and the
workplace a topic that we find probably
plenty to talk about
even more than we'd like to talk about
anyone who's had a job or considered
working knows that it comes with many
challenges most of which involve dealing
with loving people usually not the work
itself
so stoicism is particularly apt to deal
with that this is a sort of irregular
session of our normal monthly stoic
fellowship meeting and if you don't come
to those meetings please consider
yourself invited they're typically the
last Thursday right everybody yeah
except November and December will be
different because of the holidays but
the stoic community the mawaki stoic
fellowship is part of a larger stoic
fellowship and there's information for
that online for anyone who's interested
our reason for changing the date of this
month's meetup is because we are
currently in stoical week and I'm going
to ask Greg to tell us all a little bit
about stoic on and stoic week and the
modern stoicism community and how that
started but essentially I'll just
introduce myself and then invite the
other two panelists to introduce
themselves as well but I am Andy shock
I'm new to stoicism and I am a doctoral
candidate in philosophy at the European
Graduate School and my background is in
teaching and I've worked most recently
as the curriculum and program director
for the food business school for the
culinary institute of america and i'm
actually working on my dissertation on
the topic of culinary education as
sort of mode of Technology and I'm
getting great coaching and health from
Greg and he'll tell you a little bit
about our relationship and how we're
connected but essentially I'm shirking
my duties as a charity but I found
stoicism through high school practice
when we were studying for the academic
decathlon I grew up here in Wisconsin
and I went to divine Savior holy angels
and we're reading Cicero as part of our
academic Athlon training and I would
sort of a stressed out person and found
great value and some of the practices
that I was introduced to at that time
and have only found since joining the
fellowship that I am really enjoying
getting more involved in the study of
stoicism and I get a lot out of our
conversations reading epictetus I've
been doing the stoic meditations this
week as the part of a stoic week and
we'll share that information about where
you can find that online at the end of
the video if you haven't already found
that website but I find it very useful
and I'm really looking forward to the
conversation tonight my job is mostly to
facilitate discussion and field
questions I am the least experienced
person on this very distinguished panel
but I do get great joy and a lot of
personal enrichment out of working with
the stoic fellowship and just thank you
all for taking time to be through
tonight and look forward to a really
good discussion actually let me say a
few things about about Sean because Sean
is it is very self-effacing but he has
he's a graduate student at Marquette
working I'm just finishing up his
dissertation and his project that we've
talked about a number of times
commitment is a very interesting one
that he'll tell you about in a moment I
think it's a very practical one as
opposed to many dissertations which I
think just can't get written get put up
on the shelf and
do anything again I'm really looking
forward to seeing his work not only get
defended in terms of his dissertation
but also get put into the the workplace
particularly in educational institutions
and I've known Sean what about two years
now
we monthly and so you know we've talked
quite a bit I'm very impressed with the
work that he's doing he also has a blog
I forget the name of is it just Sean
know his thoughts on Miller blog that's
right yeah very interesting stuff on
there I'm a busy guy but I make the time
to read it so if that counts is any sort
of recommendation I would I would check
it out and then you should say a few
things about your your project and sure
yeah so I'm John Miller PhD candidate at
Marquette and my dissertation is on the
moral assumptions of sex education
classes in the United States and in one
particular chapter I'm looking at the
hellenistic term is called askesis and
the Stoics use it and it's basically
translated as trainings or discipline of
the self and I think that's a good way
to implement those practices into a sex
education curriculum or to formulate a
sexual subject or subjectivity to
formulate what it means to be a sexual
being and then from there learn about
the other things that you typically
learn in a sex education class my blog
is has a little bit of sausage meant
butts mostly about ideas of
relationships and sexuality and all
these journal articles that I'm
collecting in trying to formulate a
coherent structure that I think would
work well and the sex education
curriculum so I'm Greg Sadler I'm the
editor of Stoicism today which is sort
of the the biggest I would say online
magazine or blog devoted to stoicism
and it's it's part of what the modern
stoicism now ltd organization does I
finally incorporated because it's been
growing and growing and growing and as
it's been
they say scaling up we've realized we
need an actual institutional structure
we can't just be a team of people kind
of swapping ideas we need to actually
get our get our act together so they did
that recently I'm very privileged to
have some very you know great colleagues
recently they put on stoic on 2017 which
i think is this either the sixth I think
it's a sick worldwide stoic on this time
it was in Toronto there about four
hundred people there and we had a lot of
great talks and you know great plenary
session and workshops there's also these
stoic on X events which are sore like
the you know how Ted there's Ted and
TEDx stoic on tax events are smaller we
had them on four continents this year so
it's really growing the the Facebook
group for modern stoicism has I think
somewhere around thirty five thousand
members now who routinely chime in so it
gets very crowded the stoic week class
that's going on right now which it's not
too late to sign up for there are over
six thousand people enrolled online
which is up from thirty three hundred I
think last year so it's really growing
quite quite fast and I think it's in
part because you know the internet
affords us some great opportunities and
there are a lot of people doing some
some good and outreach work like you
know what we do here with MKE stoic
fellowship but it's also there's there's
a real need on the part of many people
especially in the workplace how do you
deal with to put not to find a point on
how do you deal with everybody's BS or
the stuff that you're being expected to
do how do you maintain you know some if
not necessarily a stoic stage like
equanimity at least don't lose your
your marbles right or your temper how do
you how do you get a hold on the sort of
habits and emotions that you go through
how do you deal with adversity this is
something that ancient stoicism was not
the only philosophy that that tackled
but it was it was very good in doing
that and I think that's what has
attracted people to stoicism down to the
present I wanted to say just a few words
for anybody who doesn't know much about
stoicism Sean mentioned he's looking at
Hellenistic philosophies so that means
philosophies from you know ancient
Greece which spread into Roman culture
and actually spread out across the
entire Roman Empire ended up influencing
not only Western civilization but in
terms of some of these other ones what
what was going on the Near East
sometimes even got into dialogue with
Indian civilization and stoicism was in
some ways a late comer on the scene the
guy who starts at Zeno he he was a
Phoenician guy that the story is that he
was he was a traitor he had a whole
cargo of royal purple I was very hard to
get to die and shipwrecked so he could
actually like see his wealth dissipating
into the ocean as he's you know swimming
for Shore trying to keep himself alive
and poor guy winds up in Athens in a
book stall and he's reading
kennedys.these scrolls books or Scrolls
at that time at random and he reads a
book of Xenophon and it's talking about
this socrates guy and socrates seems
like a hell of a guy
so he's like where can I find somebody
like this and Bookseller says well you
see that guy over there walking down the
street that's Pradas he's probably the
closest thing we've got to socrates craw
chase was a cynic and these cynics they
you know they were sort of like today's
minimalists in a certain way they're
sort of like the hippies in the 60s they
were very much about you know pairing
everything down and they often went
against social convention because they
thought it was
natural but their goal this is how they
might have different from some of these
these other types is they thought that
the only thing that really matter is
moral excellence or virtue everything
else you can dispense with it having a
house not that important you know money
in the bank not that important social
status doesn't matter right and so the
they were interested in liberating
themselves from that the Stoics didn't
go quite so far with that Stoics will
hold down a job cynics probably not you
know not for long right but the Stoics
you know Zeno studied with Kratt takes
for about ten years but he also took
classes with other people there's
stories about something about some of
these other classes cratchits coming in
pulling Xena out by his ear and saying
you shouldn't be studying with these
guys but Zeno did it anyways and then he
went off on his own and started his own
school at the snow apoikia leh which
becomes the thing that they're named
after and you know some of the key ideas
that they shared in common of the cynics
are this notion that living in
accordance with nature fully developed
human nature or virtue those are the
primary good for us human beings the
other stuff it's not that it doesn't
matter at all like wealth or position or
our you know what other people think of
us that that sort of stuff doesn't it's
not bad it's not something to be
rejected but we we sometimes have to
make a change in our priorities you know
we have to we have to focus on what we
actually do have control over which is
our character our ideas our habits our
reactions and even our emotions the
Stoics think we can control our emotions
at least to some degree and not so much
all the other stuff out here so that
poses some this is a good segue into
Shawn that poses some real issues for
the workplace because if you think about
it in the workplace we're dealing
primarily with what the stones called
externals or indifference these things
like how much money we're making or what
do we put in the budget or how many
hours am I going to work and I think
there's sometimes a risk for people
when they're adapting Stoicism to
setting themselves up to be exploited or
to be even abused by other people in
part because you know the Stoics
counseled you know if somebody insults
you you know it's not really them
insulting you it's it's your opinion
that you're being insulted I think we
have to take that in moderation there
are cases where somebody really is
trying to you know get one over on us
and I think that happens more often in
the workplace perhaps than in some other
venues although I will tell you if Sean
and Andy will tell you happens plenty of
the time in academia - right and it
certainly happens in the world of
relationships and in other other things
as well
so I think that's a good segue into Sean
talking about how we can use stoic ideas
in the workplace sure yeah so this is
based off my experiences in the
workplace and I'm sure it will apply to
other scenarios and other jobs as well
but most of my jobs I've had are either
in academia my teaching or in retail and
when it comes to teaching the main
frustrations are either other people
around you or tasks that you have to do
and the other people are typically
students or fellow colleagues or
sometimes being in committees with with
students that's the big one for me
whenever I teach there's always a
predictability with sort of questions
I'll ask and you know how to answer them
and you get a sense of through the
teaching that the material is going to
be predictable in terms of how they're
gonna react to it but once while you'll
get a wild card student where they'll
throw you off and you have no idea how
to respond sometimes they'll do it just
to hear their voice sometimes they'll do
it to express an opinion that may be
tangential to the topic or they just
want to show off I guess so those are
some of the frustrations I have to deal
with of the students in terms of the
tasks it's mainly grading it's something
that worst part about being it is it
really is that something about teaching
that I don't enjoy or trying to find
really abstract material presentable so
the students can understand it which is
also really challenging to when it comes
to retail against the same thing tasks
for people and usually it's the
customers that are out probably the
frustration they think they know about
the service or the good than you do or
they might be frustrated they're not
getting their product right away or
sometimes your fellow co-workers they
don't meld well with with your
personality we're usually academia your
other colleagues they kind of come from
the same sort of background so you can
kind of gel well together in terms of
personalities but with retail other
co-workers they come from different
backgrounds and so sometimes there could
be a personality clash as one example I
used to work at a different coffee shop
that I work at right now and a fellow
coworker he was promoted to a shoot a
supervisor and he just got power-hungry
and he just started controlling people
and you really wanted to show off that
who was in charge and it really
frustrated me I could tell a frustrated
the rest of the co-workers and it was
something that I had to relearn and
control about how am I gonna deal with
him
am I going to mentally prepare working
with him so those are the main ones that
I see main issues icing over place other
people or other tasks big externals I
consider so what we thought we would do
because we're gonna have a lot of just
straight-out discussion but before that
each of us has one particular practice
that we've found for us especially
useful that's I think some of that
depends on temperament too you know like
I'm a person who has to watch losing his
temper Shawn maybe not so much you know
and so different people find different
techniques or strategies more or less
useful so do you want to start Andy at
the user okay
I picked self-control in part because I
would say I struggle with it the most
and I also tend to try to over exert to
control the most so it's sort of like my
control over self and my attempt to
control others in the workplace I know
is a hot button for me there's one quote
that I've mentioned many many times but
it's from epictetus and you'll tell me
which which it's from the enchiridion
but I don't remember the book but it's
talking about acting well the character
that's assigned to you and being willing
to just simply pay it player part and I
keep returning to that one over and over
again so my work history is really
interesting in part because I could
never really settle into anything so I
worked in corporate banking I was an
assistant dolphin trainer I was a pie
maker a caterer I was a building super
in New York City so I was you know
essentially a janitor I thought they did
market research I deliver papers I was
constantly working different jobs and I
always really enjoyed that while I was
going to school because it kept things
interesting and it satisfied what
probably could really only be described
as kind of an attention deficit issue
when I got into teaching I realized that
every day was kind
of a new day and you had these short
compact moments with your students and
there were the challenges that Sean I
already identified some you know it's
it's great when you feel prepared to
come into a room and you're gonna have
this great conversation and then there's
these outliers or these things that
happen but teaching was really rewarding
for me and as I was saying earlier when
we were just talking casually it was the
kind of job that once I fell into it I
knew I always wanted to do this I mean I
really feel like I was kind of born to
do this and I didn't need to be paid I
needed to be paid because I needed to
pay my bills but if I had enough of
money I always said I would still
continue to teach because I loved it
that much and I taught in
maximum-security prisons I taught at
community colleges in the Bronx where
most of the students were
first-generation students you know their
parents hadn't gone to school at all in
many cases language was an issue so I
was teaching a lot of English language
learner courses I taught at some really
great institutions and some really
mediocre and underfunded institutions
but it wasn't really until I found
myself in need of a summer job and
assumed a position at the Culinary
Institute of America that things kind of
gelled for me and they go year-round
right so their first class is at two
o'clock in the morning their last class
ends at one o'clock in the morning I
mean it's all day and all a year except
for three weeks in the heat of the
summer where they close down to clean
all the kitchens and kind of put a fresh
face on everything for them and I had
just moved from New York City to upstate
New York and needed a teaching job to
supplement the job that I had gotten at
Marist College at the time teaching you
know really great courses on lit really
challenging students who wanted to be
there there in the major and then also
teaching for Bard College Prison
Initiative where I'm doing obviously
really challenging work but for a
different reason and I ended up in a
writing class that was culinary writing
it's the first class that you know
aspiring chefs and pastry chefs wanted
you know they wanted to be there to cook
and they got stuck in this writing class
so I had resistant learners a lot of the
learners they're like you know if I
wanted one of them said to me
I wanted to go to college I would have
gone to college you know but the CIA was
a real degree-granting institution
liberal arts foundation all of that and
I thought that I understood a lot about
teaching and about control and had
really come to a point where I was
maturing in my profession you know I was
probably two-thirds done with the
graduate courses that I was going to
take at that time before I discovered
that I was really supposed to be
studying philosophy a line kind of
started my graduate school over but I
you know I felt pretty secure in it and
I really loved teaching these students
because they were really great mixes of
right and left brain learners they
wanted to take everything apart and
understand how it worked but they also
had this really creative drive and
passionate desire and what I realized is
that I didn't understand anything about
their world and how control and acting
well the role that one is assigned and
all of these things actually worked when
you're in a hierarchical rank very
similar to I think a military structure
and you're only expected responses yes
chef when told to do something and
musiim classes not just what you do
before you cook it's a way of life and
being ten minutes early is actually late
you know and all of these great lessons
that I think I probably really needed in
my life came through the vocation that I
had chosen and this weird sort of
securities route to being in a place
that I hadn't really intended to be and
I think because of that that's where I
was able to really find and dive into
the study for philosophy that I had
wanted to do and those lessons that I
had learned and one of the most stressed
out points in my life prior to that when
I was in high school preparing for what
comes next
on this great academic decathlon team
you know my friends are going off to
college I hadn't even taken the SATs yet
you know and and found Cicero that sort
of started coming back to me and the
idea of just trying to do the best job
that I could at where I was with what I
was given
not fighting and not resisting and not
trying to control everything and
actually give over to a structure that
made sense and the Culinary Institute of
America had that structure and and chef
lice and cooking has that structure and
you know that was one of the most
powerful lessons I think that I needed
to learn in order to mature into a
better student and into a better worker
and into you know a more efficient
person
and an impact of my life great deal now
in connecting that to what we're
studying in the stoical fellowship or
lessons learned from stoicism or even
just these reflections that I'm doing
every day is part of stoical week it's
amazing to me because what I really love
about it is the simplicity and the fact
that it's so clearly stated and so
simply understood and so when I read
something like that passage and
Epictetus about acting one of the
character is I'm to you I understand
that even though it was about something
that was occurring
at the time of Epictetus it's just as
relevant to me today and it will likely
be just as relevant to someone 100 years
from now because we often time find
ourselves I think in workplace conflict
when we're trying to act someone else's
character or when we're so busy
critiquing the way that someone else is
acting their character that were not
focused on ourselves and so the the
workplace issues that I found in
academia I didn't have the same
experience Sean did rife on that people
were kind of all from a similar
background I found that some of the most
intense arguments and the most intense
character assassinations that I have
worked with nastain academic committee
meetings you know I mean people It was
as if their life depended on it
and I first got to participate as a
fellow at the college I was attending at
the time which was City College of New
York and I was so excited and I had my
little yellow pad and I was right
supposed to take notes as a fellow I got
to attend the department meetings and I
was going to take the notes and
transcribe the minutes and I was just
like throat and within about 20 minutes
you know one of the first I mean he
slams his hand on the desk and he's like
you know nothing you know nothing about
you know whatever it was I mean it was I
think a poetry term and you know I just
like remember thinking oh no what are
they done like what what is this
experience this is awful you know you're
not supposed to fight like this is the
life of the mind like I was so shattered
and it lasted about five minutes and
then I realize it's it's a job like it
is indeed a workplace and as much as I
thought that once I finally got into a
position of being able to teach and
interact with my professors as quasi
colleagues and have these great you know
conversations that it was just gonna be
constantly elevating and I'd be uplifted
and you know there'd be just reasons to
be excited every single day it was still
just a committing me you know and so
that was a very quick turnaround for me
and I think that what I observed most
and both academic settings and in the
culinary workplace and then especially
when you put those things together is
that opportunities to be offended or to
offend are everywhere and you can argue
with as much passion about whatever that
poetry term was that you know sort of
caught me by surprise as you can you
know a white pepper versus a black
pepper and a specific dish and when
people are passionate and they care
about what they're doing they're
inspired to argue and to debate and
hopefully to do it respectfully but when
people feel frustrated which is also
often the case in kitchen jobs and in
academia those arguments take on a
different tenor and they take on a
different sort of impacts and import and
so I'm no longer arguing my point I'm
venting my frustration and I'm
dissatisfied with my position and you
know it doesn't go away just because no
that's right there's that great sort of
little Instagram mean right every day
somebody is fighting a battle you know
nothing about kind of that thought
process that's most definitely true but
in the workplace I think what's
happening is that it's many battles
because it's the battle between who the
person is and who they're projecting to
be and that that in and of itself can
create conflict I know when I assume the
position as a building super I was also
teaching at the time as an adjunct to
the colleges that I was you know within
the City University of New York system
and I was walking down the street one
day to get the train and I was dressed
to teach and a woman who lived in the
building that I was supervising oh I
didn't recognize you you look like such
a normal person and it was at that
moment that I realized that when I was
taking out her trash I was no longer a
normal person right I was like class
down yeah and so you know those types of
strangeness I mean maybe you feel this
in retail but I know when I was cooking
or when I would work as a clerk at a
bookstore you learned a lot by about
people by what they throw away what they
order when they eat and the books that
they read right and maybe even how they
take their coffee or you know how picky
they are about what goes on the side on
their substitutions and their meals but
when you start to put that together and
you realize that people treat you very
differently based on how you're serving
them in the capacity of your normal day
or how you're interacting with them or
the position that you appear to have
that's another opportunity that I found
so focused on sort of like the character
I'm assigned and if I think about it
that way it really isn't so threatening
maybe to Who I am in my own identity and
I think that's probably the important
word is that people often feel
threatened in the workplace because
their intelligence can be called into
question their experience their function
their authority you know you really want
to get people angry you would start
questioning Authority and who's more
right and who's more well-versed in this
you know and I think that's the other
thing is that along with self-control
and along with recognizing my part is
part of a larger play that I may be
called upon in some cases to be servant
and in some cases to be master and just
to do both jobs graciously it helps me
keep sort of like humility in
perspective and to remember what I'm
teaching in particular that my students
are there because they desire to learn
or because someone told them that they
ought to and either way it's my job to
reach them and help them understand the
subject matter it's not my job to give
them my opinion it's not my job to lead
them to a certain conclusion but my job
to help them discover the sort of
glorious nature of inquiry and it's not
easier to look at that when you're
teaching say then when you're doing
something far less you know
inspirational for me for example I did
not enjoy doing telephone survey is for
Gallup I did not you know I could have
perhaps if I had discovered stoicism
earlier recognized that I had an
opportunity to spend two hours
interviewing someone on the phone about
their political preferences and or you
know where they shopped and or whatever
but that didn't inspire me and I
remember feeling such drudgery over that
type of work and in part because I had
maybe just understood that that at that
time was a role that I was intended to
play I will sort of close this little
period of the conversation by saying
that I know also that administration is
not for me and I did a great job at it
and I know that because they kept
getting promoted and I became ever more
miserable so when I left the classroom
and I became an assistant
and then a director and then you know
all of these progressive sort of
wonderful promotions and that it allowed
you to do so much more for the
institution and everything I wanted to
die like I literally just thought
anything you know I missed the days of
taking on other people's trash and
committee meetings when you're a faculty
member are very different or even a
student representative than when you're
part of the group you know and you pass
around these notes like you know meeting
card bingo or it's like when someone
says deliverables like click here when
you know someone says you know
tightening the budget click here you
know the little ribbons that say I
survived in a meeting that could have
been an email you know those things are
real because they're real and if we've
ever experienced them we know that
they're difficult and it's very
difficult to maintain sort of a stoic
approach to that level of inefficiency
but at the same time what I'm trying to
learn is that perhaps it's not my place
to judge the efficiency of the
inefficiency it's something to
contribute what I can in that moment and
then spend my energy that I otherwise
would have spent resenting what I was
doing on the things that allow me to be
more authentically of value to this
world you know so rather than sit around
as I often subjected Greg to like hours
of and then you know you and believe and
then this person said this you know and
you're like rehashing the whole thing so
you're not only sitting through it once
you're making the people who care about
you live it with you a second time over
dinner you know all of the time loss
where we could have been discussing as a
epictetus so that's what I try to do
with you know where I am right now which
is very very early stages of study with
stoicism and no philosophy but I say
that it probably is still and for a very
long time going to be focusing on
aspects of self control and aspects of
relinquishing control and knowing when
to do both for me at least and I think
that in the workplace
a lot of really smart people especially
people who love to learn have said some
other things to me as well so that would
probably be my okay my piece I'll answer
that sure yeah
what got me interested in assumption of
askesis
as an undergrad I was really interested
in learning how to live a good life and
trying to improve oneself and how to how
to strive and I went through various
philosophers I looked at Aristotle and
Nietzsche and for Cole and the usual
go-to was virtue ethics and so I go take
a look at Aristotle and his answer was
well instead of and so uh just coasting
through life you've got a flourish in
the way to flourishes you got obtained
the virtues and he lists off the virtues
and I thought well great how do you how
do you obtain them and his answer was
practice that's all you have to do and I
thought okay well how do you get started
with the practices and that's where it
got a little bit ambiguous for me you
would just say well you just got a start
you just got a practice and that just
felt kind of unsatisfying for me but I
stuck with it I stuck with the whole
idea of learning how to strive through
life and try to improve your life
instead of just coasting through life
and then I discovered through things
through fuko's lectures on the new
tricks of the self they talked about
this term askesis a lot and I want to
look what that was and he grabbed that
from the Hellenistic philosophers and
the more I dove into that the more I
looked into you know going back to
epicly dis trying to figure out what
askesis was and i thought this is a
better way of looking at striving a
better way of improving or updating
yourself if you all look it that way and
the whole notion of askesis from was
what i just got from Epictetus is trying
to
go through certain exercises and
techniques to improve the self so here I
have gotten some tips or some exercises
some techniques that I got from
Epictetus and it's kind of helped me try
to figure how to improve my daily life I
guess or trying to improve and trying to
strive well one thing that Epictetus
says you got to start off with just
mentally preparing yourself most of the
Hellenistic philosophers they compared
Jesus to athletic competitions or
musical competitions with athletics or
music ability you have to get better you
have to go out and you have to be part
of the competitions so that when you
practice them practice the athletic
stuff more practice them musical stuff
and you can prepare yourself for the
real thing well when you are doing
practices of the self it's not as if you
are doing all these practices to prepare
yourself for the real thing because the
real thing is part of the practices as
well so there is no distinction between
the practices and the real thing though
it's kind of blurred and so you're
always on the go you're always strive
you're always pushing yourself because
the real thing is are the practices so
how do we get better at it there's three
main practices three main exercises that
I get from emptiness the first one is
trying to train your desires or trying
to recognize what needs to be changed
and some of the other Stoics some of the
other Hellenistic philosophers they
mentioned you know going through these
daily affirmations trying to just repeat
this these Maxim's over these lines over
in your life again and again until they
just become engrained into your
character other philosophers have
mentioned writing things down that's one
that's really helped me the most is
writing things down because
right here writing things down it
solidifies your thoughts this of the
Pfizer beliefs and so that it's
structured and it's coherent and then
usually whenever I write things down in
a systematic way it reveals you oh wow
so this is actually what I believe this
is actually what I'm striving towards
and when you write things down it's not
just or do you believe or what are you
trying to reach for but certain exercise
that you can help out to achieve the
goal that you're trying to go for Seneca
for example you offer an advice of what
to do when you write things down at the
end of the day figure out what sort of
elements you've cure for the day or what
failures that you've tried to resist
where you've failed for example what
duties you forgot to do and how you can
show improvement marcus aurelius I mean
is his meditations is all about his his
daily thoughts on how to improve his
life so when you start writing things
down it it gives you a sort of
meditative way to think about your day
but it establishes a pattern about how
to live out your life and then you begin
to digest those ideas and so just
thinking them out on a superficial level
um the second thing is to train your
your actions and to train your roles and
acting out what needs to change so now
that you've recognized what needs to be
changed that you have to act those out
and you can't just rely on reading
something and then hope it kicks in
you've actually have to act those things
out in order for the a can take place
one thing that the Stoics mentioned is
to gain a new habit you have to
sometimes force yourself to do the
opposite so for example if you are
inclined to work pleasure throw yourself
in the opposite way for the sake of
training if you're inclined to be lazy
throw yourself into some sort of work
you have to do these counteracting
forces just so that you can untrain
those habits you have hopefully you
begin to take on that new habit the
correct habit another task and this is
this is actually one of my favorite
tasks and I'm starting to do this and I
kind of go back and forth on this but
it's to learn to accept rejection and
this is something from this is from NPR
show I was but one of the speakers on
there his name is Jason Connelly and he
started this concept called rejection
therapy oh yeah it was it's a it's an
interesting idea he he had throughout
his life he he was just really miserable
really depressed and he decided just one
day to go for a walk or how to go get
some groceries and just out of the blue
he asked a woman if he could have some
gum and she said no he went to the store
bought some milk and asked the cashier
do you mind if I get a discount on this
milk and she said no and he actually
felt better and over time he thought you
know I can actually see this rejection
as something I can help me out so what
he did after that for that episode is he
took a deck of cards and he put on
certain tasks and you have to take a
card each day and do that task and the
goal is to be rejected about the day so
some of them are pretty simple like
asking a stranger for some gum or going
to a place to shop and ask for a
discount or asking if they could if you
can take a sip of someone's drink some
of them more challenging so are much
more challenging ones guys one of them
is asked calling up your bank to see
they could avoid any fees and then yeah
you can see how that you'd be rejected
from there but that's the rule that call
me had be rejected by a stranger at
least once a day now no one likes to be
rejected but eventually you begin to
learn rejection that's a part of life
and if you can train yourself to learn
that you will be rejected then
the steam won't come as bad and as soon
as you practice rejection then when you
get rejected in real life you can deal
with it you can take it and it might
sting but it won't be as bad if you
didn't have that training the third
exercise is to stay constant with those
previous trainings and to solidify those
new habits and again with athletics or
musical ability the best way to do that
is to find your weak spots and target
those in playing a musical instrument
maybe there's certain bars that you
really weak at you just practice them
over and over again maybe if you are in
some sort of dance competition and
there's a a movement that you really
weak at maybe you should practice that
movement again and again until it's
perfected the same thing is with you
find any weak spots with perfecting the
self where are some things that you find
we add and just work on those and by
working on those hopefully you can
improve that portion and then that will
slow with the rest of your life and then
everything else in life will just flow
with that app my job some way weak spots
are dealing with the wild card students
I'm still trying to figure out ooh do
that it's really challenging really
tough because of their unpredictability
but sometimes I can figure out what to
do in terms of how to handle them but
once again they are always wild cards
and so it always throws me off and at
the end at the end of the day or maybe
at the end of the semester I just look
back and I shrug and I laugh and think
well that was an interesting moment what
I want experience it again probably not
but they're very likely going to forget
about me I'm very likely going to forget
about them and that's that's life and
that's the stoic attitude so recognize
what needs to be changed actually do the
changes and then solidify those new
habits
you have those are the main three
exercises I got from askesis and those
are the things that helps to update or
to improve your life and as soon as you
have those new habits solidified then
upgrade yourself again and just keep
doing that until you improve very
similar to athletics or musicianship so
it's kind of like an iterative process
yeah yeah so what I have to say actually
fits in quite well with some of what
we've discussed so far and I all start
actually with something that's connected
with what Andy was saying about going
into the committee meeting and seeing
what professors are really like I got
interested in stoicism originally in a
non-academic way as I was you know of
course reading epictetus because we had
to in philosophy classes but I got
interested in the starts because I
struggled a lot with anger and I
struggled since I was a kid it got to
the point so bad that I ended up
becoming a ward of the court my mother
actually filed an uncontrollability
petition that that you know because
things were so bad I was getting in
fights very aggressive and you know I
went through my my teens and my 20s
really having a hard time with that and
so I would look for resources and I
didn't find a lot of the anger
management stuff that people were giving
me particularly helpful I think some of
that may you know in retrospect someone
that made that I wasn't ready to hear it
but I you know I I was good in
philosophy and there's a whole funny
story about how I ended up in philosophy
I could tell some other time because
that's a pretty random as well but i and
i'm studying graduate studies in
philosophy down at southern illinois
university and still getting in you know
very bitter arguments with my colleagues
would be graduate students you know and
I knew that I had anger problems and
then I would I would go to these
meetings and see my professors who are
supposed to be rational right these this
is philosophy these are people teaching
ethics you think
they're supposed to know what the hell
they're doing in terms of their psyches
and they're shouting at each other
getting in each other's faces and and
not just the guys even the women two are
doing this occasionally and then
sometimes there'd be like that the ones
who didn't raise their voice but would
engage in passive-aggressive jockeying
with each other and I you know I was
like I know I'm screwed up what the
hell's wrong with these people you know
and so I had this real impetus for
looking at you know theories in it and
and I found that virtue ethics have had
better explanations than a lot of the
other theories that were out there a lot
of the psychological theories come out
of philosophy anyway so Aristotle I I
liked quite a bit Plato I like quite a
bit but what I really liked from the
Stoics was that they gave us a number
that I had a sort of a similar thing
with Aristotle
Ursel gives us a nice math but he
doesn't tell us a lot of techniques to
use to actually deal with some troubling
emotion like anger and anger is one of
the most complicated of the emotions
it's you know dealing with this very
widespread problem it arises over and
over and over again it ties in with
control because anger often makes us
feel as if we're more in control that's
how it seduces us so that people are
like hey you're really going over the
lines you're like I'm fine you know it's
the whole world that's screwed up
because thudded me so anger you know the
Stoics head had a lot to tell us about
it now they go a bit further than I
actually would like to and even somebody
who's not a stoic who I really like
who's influenced by them Cicero goes a
little bit further in having a total
zero tolerance policy about anger
angers always bad we want to avoid it in
every case I don't go quite that far but
I think they have a lot of really
helpful things to say about it because
even if we're like Aristotelian and we
say there might be some occasions where
we should get angry those are pretty
rare Aristotle says that the person who
has a good disposition with respect to
anger in Greek the prowess the the mild
temper
gentle they often don't get angry when
other people do and when they do get
angry it's within certain limits
well the Stoics say no no you shouldn't
get angry at all but here's how how to
deal with it and so one of the things
that I find very helpful in the
workplace it has to be done in the right
way and I'll tell you about that in just
a minute is coming from epictetus but
you can also find it in Marcus Aurelius
and in Seneca and other thinkers and if
you want to be a little facetious we
could call up the oh you poor bastard
doctrine where when you look at why
people do the stuff that takes us off
and there's a lot of things that do take
you know managers make stupid decisions
you're like why did you make that
decision well it works out good for for
them you know or the it kind of fits in
with some ideology that they have or who
knows what or you know the
superintendent made me do it right and
then you look at like customers and why
do they act like jerks and co-workers
what what the hell is wrong with them
right all these sorts of things are
people are are getting on our nerves are
irritating us why are they doing it is
it because they really want to hurt us
it's because they think that what
they're doing is the right thing for
them to do on some level and there's
there's an objection that can get made
and I'll talk about that in a minute
they'll just stick with this for a
second
on some level Epictetus says the thief
thinks that it's good it's right it's
rational to steal other people's stuff
and you could like talk to them and say
did you see that like now this guy over
here you stole the stuff out of his
garage you can't do the project that
he's supposed to be working on don't you
feel like a jerk now and and sometimes
they could say yeah you had a coming too
or everybody you know just should take
each other's things or you know people
can be quite hardened about that so
there can be sort of a second level or
you can you can be like I like screwing
people over you know I like sticking it
to them well it just means it on a
higher level they're screwed up about
what it is that
is rational or good or right for them
you know because it's on some level they
think that it makes sense as a human
being to be sticking it to other people
or to be getting in you know shouting
matches with them in the workplace and
after Tina says and I think he's right
about this if you if you instead of
adopting the perspective of they're bad
people because of that and therefore I'm
entitled to feel angry at them and I
should like take revenge on them in some
way you say the equivalent of you poor
bastard you know you don't actually say
this to them of course this is one of
the don't dues but you say in your mind
you're poor bastard you have no idea
what the hell you're doing Marcus
Aurelius talks about this and that that
very famous thing every day wake up and
say to yourself I'm gonna meet a whole
bunch of Schmucks I'm gonna meet people
who are ungrateful who are contentious
and you know we can fill it in with
whatever blanks we need because every
workplace has different challenges right
and then he goes on and he says here's
the deal they don't understand what the
good is for human beings they're deluded
about that they think that they know
what it is you do know what it is so
don't act like them and instead of you
know getting angry at them or hating
them treat them even with affection
because they're your fellow human beings
this is kind of similar to when
epictetus says everything it's two
handles one by which you can pick it up
the other by which you can't and uses an
example of your brother's a jerk to you
do you pick it up by the handle my
brother is a jerk that handles the
handle of anger and retribution already
pick it up by the handle of well he's
still my brother so I'm gonna exercise
my role towards him even though he
doesn't do it at all towards me because
that way you can carry there out and
then we could say that their co-workers
right my coworker is supposed to
actually help me out with the task that
I'm assigned and they don't do it well
should I be angry at them or should I
say they're doing that because they're
they're mixed up about stuff and an
epictetus says if you do this it's good
change the way that you feel instead of
feeling angry at them you're gonna feel
something that in the Greek and then the
older translations we say is pity all
right pity towards them and that's where
that you poor bastard thing sort of
comes in seems a little patronizing
doesn't it
so that's why you don't say it to them
directly another word that would
translate the Greek term Alejo s is
compassion and so you can think of it as
being compassionate towards the person
or if you don't like that understanding
understanding why they're messed up the
way they are and notice this doesn't
require you to make any excuses for them
and to say that what they're doing is is
okay because it might not be okay you
know it doesn't require you to say that
they're not psychologically screwed up
they are psychologically screwed up
that's part of why they act the way that
they do it doesn't require you even to
forgive them or definitely not to forget
you know what they're doing I mean it
doesn't say well forget about it and
then like let them do the same thing
over and over again you can prudently
say not gonna work on joint projects
with you anymore buddy you know or we're
not gonna we're not gonna sign you any
positions responsibility I gonna let you
do the budget because when you do you
mess it all up right it doesn't preclude
any of those sort of decisions that we
would have to make but what it does is
it frees us up to not feel angry and
again it's a person who's been angry way
more of the time in my life that I wish
I I would have been it's liberating when
when you don't have to feel angry in a
situation this is where the CSIs comes
in Epictetus says you have to work at
this so Sean mentioned Epictetus says
this metaphor of like the ship is
tilting this way you got to push it way
back this way to get it to come to stay
in the middle so if you're an angry
person you got to do stuff that can
this actually this is hard to do because
once you're angry you're like screw
hepatitis you know who the hell's need
to tell me what I needed but you gotta
force yourself to go to the other
extreme and you don't actually stop like
being angry for a long time but you feel
each time you feel a little less angry
and you have a little bit more control
and it gets better and better and better
you're still always getting you have
some people in the workplace who really
push your buttons inevitably I think
right no matter what workplace you're in
but you can it's up to you what you you
do in relation to that and again to
close on the philosophy professor thing
I mean it's funny that we you know as a
profession academic philosophers are
pretty underdeveloped psychologically I
think you know they don't do a lot of
this stuff and if they if they spent
less time on the very abstruse problems
or issues that they're working on and
more time reading practical philosophy
and applying it I think they'd be way
happier people and they'd make their
colleagues happier and their students
happier too because there's a lot of
sour bitter people out there in academic
positions boy it didn't one thing I did
want to say so there there's good ways
to do this and bad ways to do right so
you don't say to the person you poor
bastard you don't know it you know what
what's wrong cuz that's just gonna set
them off right and now if you're
actually trying to work out your anger
getting in an argument with somebody
else probably not a good way to working
out all right and I think it's very
important to not allow oneself to feel a
sense of superiority to be
passive-aggressive about it because
that's going to be counterproductive for
one's own development and it's probably
not it's it's not fair to the other
person too so that's that's what I
thought I would talk about
probably the stuff I know the most about
by experience and what we wanted to do
was to open it up to sort of group
discussion what what issues you're
struggling with or what stoic practices
you found particularly useful we're
going to hear from you guys because just
work with you get hired for a job this
is going to be
a supply chain supervisor so over the
years because I too have been in a lot
of different workplaces one of the
things that really helps me get through
it is that through this workplace
because spending just so much time with
them as you work with your actual family
I am NOT a student of sillas ISM if
someone acts in a way that I know is my
skin it's not taken as a personal of
what it's simply there for the grace of
God I go I aro perception of the world
is causing them to at least I'm a very
young person so I'm not gonna back this
if I know that much about the world but
for what I've seen when someone becomes
upset by situation or they're confused
or they're angry that management made a
decision to leave them at that same
planet it's going to lead to chaos
instead you've got to counteract in a
way that will let them know that you're
compassionate about why there instead of
be greeted by their emotions or
destructive ads and thinking that
it's a recognition that this is really
liberating I think when you give
compassion in the place of anger you
know I had one terrible terrible my
worst worst working experience was with
a manager who just I mean I could have
said like well I'm just gonna put the
thing that bought if that is there you
know I mean it one of those things
around like I'm gonna have a seat but if
that is a chair you know it's just like
you're like oh okay and everything was
always wrong and once I realized as you
were saying the sort of you poor bastard
thing annoying yeah I could have come in
every day and men like here's a million
dollars and I made you your favorite
meal and I've also decided that I'm
going to take you on vacation for our
meeting where you tell me everything I
did wrong you know and it would have
been well you know you forgot this like
you forgot that I don't like the million
dollars and when you're in those
situations the only thing you can do is
have compassion right because that
probably is somebody's aunt that's why
we have all the Thanksgiving jokes
you're right it is the family dynamic in
many ways and often times I know at
least with some of the jobs I worked I
spent more time with my work family than
I did with my at home family by you know
hours and hours and hours every week so
that's that's really interesting that is
really yeah compassion is the way to go
right
cause otherwise you can you get just as
destroyed when you pick it up by the run
handling you are also Dan
not just that person by not giving them
maybe the benefit of your compassion or
the benefit of the doubt but you're
hurting yourself as an [ __ ]
yeah day in day out
yeah so you're confronted with the
choice either you're going to let that
fester and eat away at your very yeah
yeah you know and the you know the
Stoics don't say like don't say anything
about anything they just say well
somebody's doing something wrong tell
them they're doing something wrong
there's the right way to say that and
then don't expect that that's gonna
change them because I mean they're
they're obviously invested in the way
that things are so epictetus talks about
socrates who he mentions more often than
lindsey know and he says socrates
reached one and a thousand people which
is probably if you look at the Platonic
dialogues probably about accurate for
the amount of time because they they put
him to death you know he clearly didn't
convince the jury they they they
executed him he may not have he may have
been throwing that but that didn't stop
their deputy as this point that didn't
stop Socrates from actually saying to
people hey well you should look at
things this way and Marcus has very
similar stuff and remember Marcus is the
guy who is in charge he is not just a
CEO he is you know like the the CEO of
the biggest corporation you can think of
and the President to the USA and you
know whatever else you want to roll into
it all in one he's the Roman Emperor and
he says to himself you know he's
influenced by epictetus the remind you
to remind yourself think things are
wrong tell the people they're wrong but
then just you know don't expect them to
actually change it doesn't mean that you
like let them get away with it if you're
in charge it's like imagine having an
employee where you know they're getting
in conflicts with their fellow employees
you say look you really gotta figure out
why you're arguing with every
and disrupting meetings that doesn't
mean that you would you would say as a
manager well they do that because they
see things in a certain way so I'm not
going to you know put anything in there
their file about that or reprimand them
but but you can certainly do that
without anger right you can do that by
way of saying listen I kind of coach you
because even if you leave here if we
fire you you're gonna go to the next
place and you're gonna be miserable and
you're gonna make everybody else
miserable but then they can still reject
it you know it's interesting that with
the trial Socrates in the u.s. who
sentence guilty and they asked him what
sort of punishment you want the answer
was I want free lunch results three
handles for most of my life and that's
that would create the rest of the jury
so funny you know him to death and yeah
I'm thinking in a workplace you
definitely don't want to push the other
prints of buttons in order to make them
more angry because that's just kind of
more contentious I've noticed that if I
can if I'm working with someone that
isn't my particularly favorite I will
purposely try not to push the buttons
but I like the notion of trying to be
compassionate I try to find some sort of
similarity so we can find some sort of
bridge in order to have a common feature
to roll with and then from there
hopefully things will become smooth in
terms of working with that person bridge
building I think is the best thing I can
do it by the compassion that's it's
probably beyond what I can do with some
of my coworkers
you're not the only one what else
he's been studying sunk into the monitor
there for example yesterday I was I've
gone through three rounds of interviews
for a new position that was yeah I was a
new student taking I've got the
rejection letter if you go and I know it
and the previous point my life that my
the reaction I would have gotten would
have been significantly worse yeah um
and there was that happen dis look
really the that is in a different I had
don't have any control are very little
control that I did the best I could
I'm happy about the process I was in the
interview process
and whoa whoa there's other
opportunities in this the next place
that I go I've done a lot of stuff with
lots of nonprofits and volunteer
organizations power and and that's an
extra level of you can't use the the
threats of unemployment in order to
coerce the people that are working with
you in order to these things that we
want them to do as well so they agreed
to do and a lot of times of what sort of
these insensitive things they're not
getting paid so it's not their first
priority you have other jobs for what
more other obligations that always take
precedence over this you have to create
those those bridges using your
passionate trying to understand that
person as well it's possible in order to
buy the things that you can say like you
want this yeah and I want this and this
is how we can get to here can we give it
and then for the people that caused me
great consternation with in some of the
meetings here just like really using
that so distancing to you know what you
are you are not the thing that you
pretend to be are the pearance yeah yeah
parents
the order doesn't appear to not you know
yeah the thing that you pretend to beef
and so and also the don't let someone
rent space in your head
yeah yeah Epictetus has that that that
thing where he says look you'd be
ashamed if you let anybody take control
of your body so why why don't you see it
the same way with your mind you know
anytime that you desire something that
somebody else fundamentally has control
over you make yourself their slave you
know so if it's the approval of the
crowd now you're not screwed because
they're fickle you know they can clap
her move you know be totally silent you
know I remember one one time I gave it a
talk and I was too thorough in doing the
time cuz I found this out afterwards and
II was actually there
I gave a talk on Jeremy Bentham's theory
of action was at Marist College and I
had you know the slides and handouts and
and I talked for like about an hour or
so and I got to the end of it and I was
like does anybody have any questions and
nobody had any questions there wasn't
anything even my colleagues and I was
like that's really weird you know and
you feel kind of bad you're like today
say something wrong or you don't no idea
so I went up to my colleagues afterwards
and they're like yeah it was so thorough
I couldn't think of anything to ask you
know but at the time you're like this
doesn't feel good at all he actually -
that's another thing to point out - of
the job interviews they're totally a
black box
you never know really what went into why
you didn't get this position and you
there's a temptation this is something
that really applies to you if you go for
academic jobs like when you don't get
them because most of them you won't
you know ii liked reading but what did i
do this wrong or could i have said this
or and you you're never going to know
and it's like totally waste the time
unless you actually have some sort of in
where somebody was in in that that
hiring committee and you can get them to
fess up and they don't want to do that
usually because they like my ability
right so you're you just you just can't
get anything out of it so it becomes a
fruitless endeavor but we easily spend
lots of time brooding on that sort of
thing
i think relationships to another good
example right somebody breaks up with us
they have a reason why they broke up
with us might not be the real reason we
don't really know you know it's not
worth brooding over i liked your comment
about just feeling secure in that you
did the best that you go i think that's
probably one of the bigger takeaways for
me too is just releasing the desire to
understand absolutely everything about
what happened and knowing you know it
sounds so cliched but that whole idea of
like this just isn't your tribe then
right if you weren't welcomed into this
tribe it's not your tribe your tribe is
somewhere else yeah but you know in the
work that we've done i mean greg and i
do a lot of pro bono work and what's
always it sounded me is some of the
least gracious grateful clients are the
ones who are getting all of my time for
free you know and and that has something
to do end up with that with that
volunteering thing where i you know i
would say well here's the resources and
i hope this is helpful to you and you
know good luck and now here's your next
step and i know i had one client who
said we're not gonna work with me
anymore and i was like well we had an
agreement and you know you've now met
this stop and here's your next you know
i can i suggest this and i mean it was
just personal attacks and emails and you
know this is terrible one i feel like
you're breaking up with me i mean it's a
very emotional thing and i was totally
caught off guard but it's the incentive
issue and i think that's part of what
you're saying too it's sort of how do i
find that common language we clearly
didn't have a common understanding of
what that relationship was so i can be
like whoa where is this coming from
i gave you you know thousands of dollars
worth of free consulting time this is
insane or i can say wow what was i
thinking because clearly I didn't do my
job to make sure that this was actually
you know the right fit or I didn't
communicate clearly what was happening
and I just have to accept that that's
the case this is not someone I'm ever
going to kind of bring back into the
fold and get them to see my way you know
it's it's one of the things that when
when you try to put this into practice
in a relationship right like a marriage
I don't know that Gregg and I are
particularly successful at saying now I
think we're having a misunderstanding
right now and let's take a step back and
really look at sort of what you're
saying what I'm saying I mean we'd like
to think that that's what I do sometimes
sometimes we actually do I mean but
that's more because of the nerdiness of
both of us then like any real truly
evolved developed self right I mean yeah
should I say something I think sometimes
the arguments are about who's starting
the the argument or who's taking the
conversation off track that's right that
can become a point of contention or you
can easily get into these and this is
this happens in the workplace you're
like yeah who's really at fault and it
like escalates and escalates and
escalates and you know it's interesting
because if you're if you're like a
co-worker and you're kind of at a lower
level you're a bit restricted and how
much of that you can do before they'll
can you before the security comes in and
takes you away but if you're like in you
know these
get up level these people be like
shouting at each other throwing things
and and unless somebody like actually
like flips the switch and says all right
you're fired security get them out of
here though they'll do that and I think
that happens with like in academics
sometimes with the administrators once
they start getting into like a turf war
yeah it reminds me there's this whole
series of talks there's a company I
think they're called vital smarts and
they're the ones that do like Crucial
Conversations and crucial confrontations
man like this whole series of escalating
management you know training for solving
workplace dilemmas and we went through
it at one of the places I worked and I
brought home the workbook and I was like
you know telling Greg again like okay
the thing we're finding a common ground
you know and and he was like well that's
just you know this philosophical theory
and that's this is you know practicing
stoicism so I think that's the other
thing is the workplace there's a great
book and I think it was called the gurus
and it took like all of the like of the
day you know kind of management thoughts
and it said here's where the actual
orientation is because they just keep
rehashing the same thing it's basically
you know The Four Agreements right take
nothing personally be impeccable with
your word like all of these other things
do your best if you do those things
either your life would be happier but
everyone else has to do them right is
try and be receptive to them otherwise
it feels like you know kind of fruit
falling on Rotten groan that is one good
thing about stoicism is you're not
dependent on other people being Stoics
in order for it to work yes right we're
as well like the Crucial Conversations
get it both parties like yeah in the
same thing and they both have to have
read the boy yeah he said Italy where
level three stoicism it's Kenneth and I
think this is this holds for other
things it's it's taking into account
that we we're gonna live in a world that
is not a stoic world
yeah but stoicism can give us
tools to figure out what the hell's
going out in the situations over again
one thing that's helped me is I try to
take a look at the situation right now
had a broader or objective levels of in
my personal level and whenever something
happens that I may get embarrassed or
something that doesn't work out right I
look at it objectively and think oh that
was actually kind of funny if I can look
back on it one of the example off the
top my head was a while ago I was
teaching and the stewardess laughing and
giggling and whispering to each other I
had no idea what was going on and then
the class was over and that I realized
my fly was undone and I was embarrassed
about at the time but now I can look
back on it and just laugh at it and I
try to do that
not retroactively Lee but now I look at
it right at that moment and when that
moment happens I just quickly laugh at
myself and think oh well that's what
happened I mean earlier earlier today
while we were recording I was drinking
some water and water just bit to my face
so I just laughed because oh well I know
that years from now look back at I'm
left just laugh right now
yeah the fly thing is kind of funny
because I've had the experience of like
being in the classroom unfortunately
there's a podium and you realize that
your fly's undone and you're like now
everybody's looking at me how can I get
this zipped up without anybody noticing
that I'm sipping up my fly okay how many
start thinking about it and it can
distract you from what what it is that
you're supposed to be doing which is
teaching these students you know so the
best thing is just stay behind podium
that or like you say there's something
going on in Hall and like go out in the
hall for a second then come back in the
brooding thing to this I think it's from
William Irvine he says that if you're
walking along and a dog is barking at
you you really don't care it's not gonna
affect you you just think oh it's a dog
and you just move on with the rest your
life all of a sudden if it's a person
who's yelling at you all of a sudden you
care and why is that why is it that you
don't care about the dog what you care
about this stranger mmm just basically
does the same thing and I think her
Vines suggestion was that if they're
really essentially the same thing then
you know just try to treat it as well
this thing happened try to not let it
affect you in the same way as a dog
barking at you doesn't affect you yeah
heat so the book that Shawn is talking
about is a guide to the good life which
was a very nice book an Irvine isn't
another nice way of you get kennedys of
the like a creative vocabulary for
modern stoicism might say he talks about
you know who's talking about like
outcomes so he talks about the
difference between focusing on outcomes
and internalizing the goals and so we
can have goals that are directed towards
outcomes and then we kind of place
herself in a vulnerable situation so
those outcomes don't turn out the way
that we want like somebody you know
somebody's supposed to like us and they
don't like us but instead they say
terrible things about us then we were
very upset if we make our goals
primarily just internal goals which
which do extend to the outside thing I'm
gonna try to do the best that I can then
it remains within our control and we
don't get upset
Epictetus says this great example of a
musician who knows their craft and yet
is very anxious about a performance and
so epictetus says what's going
on here what's wrong with this guy the
fact that he has not just talent but
expertise means that he can reliably
perform he can he can do things he might
screw up and I didn't one of the things
about performers is when they screw up
they know what to do next to get things
back on track right so what is he what
is he anxious about it's about the crowd
and what their response is going to be
because you can have the perfect
performance and everybody can be like oh
you suck you know you're not as good as
that this this other guy over here who
you know is not any good or we didn't
want you know that song we wanted this
song it's that musicians whether the
cancer musicians you know they hate
being told by the crowd with what song
to play because it's a big production to
get everybody on stage to do this sagar
that song and an epic Tina says if this
guy didn't care about what the crowd
response was he'd be perfectly happy and
you know what what else do we know - if
you are anxious that's when you're
probably going to screw up you know
so it even renders the sort of
performance of what what Irvine is
calling internalized goals difficult to
do what do you when you're overthinking
like am I getting the right response
from the audience yeah it's like Josh
pace the committed impulse way of actor
training and if you if you google him
you'd recognize him right away it's he's
like there's everything he plays to keep
you guys on Law & Order yeah he does but
he also plays like you know he plays so
many different wonderful characters he
has this whole committed impulse
training and it's as applicable to
acting as it is to executive work right
and he said you know just you have to
tell yourself I'm back like if you start
to feel anxious you don't fight the
anxiety you say I'm anxious and I'm
gonna use that and I'm back like I'm
back in the moment this is the moment
I'm feeling it this
what makes me a feeling thinking person
this is what makes me good at what I do
and we spend so much time fighting what
we're feeling like you were sitting just
laughs right yeah realize that later it
will be funny even if right now it feels
horrific and find the find the funny in
it but yeah I mean it's it's a challenge
regardless of of what your position is
or your workplace humor is an
interesting thing I mean the Stoics were
not known for being particularly
humorous so there were other ancient
philosophers who were but and again
Irvine is written a book recently on how
to take insults you know I think it's
good what does it call like a blow to
the face or something like that and he
suggests what he calls insult pacifism
and this does come from Epictetus in a
certain way because like epictetus let's
say somebody says bad stuff about you
say clearly they don't know me because
if they did they'd say much worse stuff
right because you know then they'd
actually know where to really hit me and
and there's a lot of funny stuff in the
Stoics but there's something about him
or that disarms if it's done right I
mean there's good I'll slap in the face
yeah I mean there there's some humor
that just we talked about punching down
all right it's a way of hurting people
but there's a lot of humor that disarms
situations I think and that could be
that could be useful to practice I like
to laugh at stuff I saw
any other comments or thoughts well
thanks for for joining us here this is I
mean so the EM cage stoic fellowship and
I hope that you guys will come to our
regular meetings where this we're
studying Seneca we studied Epictetus we
try it we do this sort of thing where we
get together and we talk about how we
apply it how it fits into our lives so
there's sort of a almost dialectic
there's the study and then there's the
where does it meet up and it's good to
talk with other people about about this
our next two meetups are Thursday
November 30th and Thursday December 21st
and they are both here at the library we
are sometimes down here and sometimes
upstairs in the community room adjacent
to the children's room but I think
starting in 2018 will almost always be
down here down here yeah sometimes we
bring snacks usually someone brings some
sort of say we're a nice group yeah it's
great and I should I should say
something
- so MKE stoical fellowship it's a local
organization but there's a larger stoic
fellowship that's like worldwide Maps
pretty impressive actually when you look
at it yeah I mean there's so there's a
people in Australia Europe North and
South America I don't think you know mr.
Dublin Helsinki yeah I don't know that
we have anybody in Africa or Asia
but it's um the whole idea is to promote
local face-to-face meetups because you
can do all this cool stuff online but
there's something about actually getting
together with and talking with people
building going
community that's that's kind of nice so
we have a lot of people who attend
regularly and I really get a lot out of
it myself
yeah any other thoughts
oh well so I I'm an eclectic I I used
stuff coming from stoicism and also the
Aristotelian tradition and some
existentialist stuff various other
things together and it was never like
there's never like one moment where I
finally is like ah cross the line and
now I'm out of like a guy who's really
got anger problems - a guy who just has
to watch something like alright it's
kind of approximate - I don't write and
II could probably tell you better than
me because she actually sees me you know
day day after day right I think it's I
think he's I don't even hesitate I'm
laughing cuz I'm hesitating because it
seems to imply something that isn't
there I think that every teacher you
progress as one should if they're
working on this and I think that what's
interesting to me is that observing you
you no longer get angry about littler
things that would previously have
bothered you a great deal well and I
think that is great progress because
often times we try to measure against
like boys get angry I mean we are very
boneheaded people and when we get along
it's amazing and when we have
disagreements neither one of us want to
yield yeah as have many you know strong
couples throughout the ages I'm gonna
say but when you look at daily life in
the practice I think that that's the
thing that I've been most impressed by
is your ability to put distance between
yourself and inconvenience connected
anger because it's like you said in your
work on anger general or Aristotle and
anger there are reasons to be angry that
are very righteous than just reasons and
one ought to be angry and if you don't
get angry for those reasons there's
probably something wrong
you write but they're rare but they are
rare but yes I mean it's I think I think
you ever think to and this is where like
the idea of community and studying and
community is really helpful is that when
you observe a change in someone that
you're regularly connected to it makes
it easier to reflect on change for
yourself and I think that that might be
a good takeaway too is that even though
stoicism doesn't require everyone to be
you know engaged it's the same practice
I think that there are rippled effects
especially if you start seeing
noticeable changes with people that you
do spend a lot of time with like those
in the workplace and you notice oh wow
you know I was really expecting that
person so like go to town in the meeting
on the southern prison buddy Danny
didn't you do notice that even if you're
not invested in that relationship so you
know I can't tell you I'd write it in
retrospect one thing that did make a big
difference and I don't know how was
teaching at a maximum-security prison
yeah I did for my first six years of my
my post graduate career at an Indiana
State Prison and it was a good place to
teach in part because there was almost
like a whole culture of Education there
and I got to know a lot of the guys and
I kind of think about it and like some
of my raw fur pointed edges got kind of
wanted off but I don't exactly know how
it happened
I just know that I was less angry and
more able to see what was going on with
me you know what angers are often
connected to pain and lack of
connectivity
I think you know your example like share
didn't get the coffee are we really
gonna like hate sharing for the rest of
your life
we have no idea what sharing and so when
you're feeling angry and when you're
feeling pain they oftentimes project
much and in very similar ways and
through any kind of thoughtful
reflective study that you can improve
both you know the tendency toward a
negative emotion but also the healing
capacity of like sort of being kind and
good to yourself because all of us don't
practice at least that we've been
reading together really is about ways to
care for the self and then also care for
others yeah you know in Seneca suggests
being forgiving to ourselves we're gonna
like screw up over and over and over
again but you know we don't have to like
we'd have to turn instead of like just
being angry at everybody else I don't to
be angry at myself
Stud yeah well there's one there is one
other possibility so you're right
everything that we've done we can't
change the actions we can reframe them
both for like getting better meaning
again like it better why the hell was I
did I see that thing there first maybe
like who that and then we can also like
we can think about the effects that
they've had on other people and if we
want to try to make up for it or undo it
or something like that you know I know
I've often been impressed by people who
came up later on and said you know month
ago I said this thing I was really wrong
about that I'm sorry for doing that you
know that that takes a lot of commitment
I think to see through right but I think
that would be perfectly consistent with
stoic practice they are making amends
for yeah and there's probably some
things we can't undo you know screw up
big enough but we didn't try to do
something some things like it feels like
throughout you know if you've really
screwed things up with somebody it feels
like you're throwing like peas and
bucket the size of this room but yeah
that's the key right you have to be
willing to save the apology and really
be sincere and say wow you know I did
this a month ago or a year or five years
or whatever and be perfectly willing to
accept the fact that they are not going
to forgive you
yeah right knowledge you or anything
else it can't be about you making
yourself coerce about having the dumbest
thing you just have to give it away and
hope and that's I mean that's very hard
to do yeah because I think a lot of
people make apologies because they think
it's gonna produce an action on the part
of the other person right like we're
cool
sorry about several things we've got cuz
I have a favor I'm asking two weeks I
think it's probably a big thing in the
workplace it's probably a lot of bosses
who don't know how to properly make up
for what they've asked employees to do
you know yeah we really need you to work
this overtime you know we'll make it up
to you then they never make it up to you
one of the things I think in an economy
like ours most people find themselves
doing is more work with less resources
and less help and support that then
becomes right the new normal yeah that's
a big problem you know in the past like
was an industrial work was really our
the main center of things they would
talk about rate setting right and you
you know you didn't want anyone to work
much harder than the average rate
because then the the bosses would say
well okay clearly we can increase the
amount and you know great example this
this this Foxconn deal that we have one
of the things that's come out is they're
very Taylor right in their management
which means that like every single thing
is sort of measured out and a lot of the
people who they were you know looking at
in other plants that that this company
runs they're not happy with them with
the workplace that they're and in part
because our that sort of managing all
your moments thing going on and I think
that's that's a dynamic that it's we're
facing much more of that than say our
parents were or our grandparents I think
it's interesting to remember this is the
last thing I'll say cuz they know we're
way over time but yeah in terms of that
media versus everywhere else that you
know you work there was a point where
you know staffing shortages were an
issue and I'm never gonna say what
university this was at but there was a
big all faculty meeting and they were
taking an entire section of the teaching
faculty and assigning them with this
like first year experience course that
was mandated at that time by the state
not Wisconsin a different state and I
remember one of the faculty members
Jenna
was very angry and said we are not
widget makers these classes are not
widgets you cannot just place us in
these classes you know I'm an economist
and I know nothing about you know life
skills I know you didn't say that but I
mean it was one of those things were
like that is sort of how we measure in
an information intellectual you know
sort of everything is on the information
exchange now and yeah I don't need to go
to school to learn how to do this skill
and I can you know get badges through
crud Lee and they're only meaningful if
someone is willing to take them as
meaningful but you know it it's really
funny kind of that line you know we're
smart people we do what our area is yeah
right well so this is a good place to
close and we'll say just that I think
stoicism has a lot of great potential
for helping us work through our
workplace issues and have a happier and
also more productive way of living one
that's more harmonious with other people
yeah so thanks very much for your time
and attention and your coming out on a
Thursday night thanks to our panel I'm
glad that you guys you know wanted to do
this it was great fun and hopefully you
see people in November yeah yeah all
right all right